- Megan you could sit
right there, you can sit.
- Hi.
I love that Megan's dress, I
saw a trail of disco balls.
- [Megan] Yeah, I'm a
Become a disco ball today.
Have ya'll met today?
Meet Megan if you haven't met.
- Hi.
- Congratulations.
- Nice to meet you. Thank you so much.
- She's having a boy.
- Well, yeah. So amazing.
- Thanks. You had a baby, congrats.
- Thank you, thank you, yeah.
- [Kelly] You did. You and Kaley.
- Yeah.
- Who I love. I'm such a big fan of her.
So, how's it going?
- It's amazing.
- [Kelly] Baby girl.
- It's the best thing ever.
She's about 10 days old.
- [Megan] Days?
- Yeah, days.
- [Megan] What are you doing here?
(everyone laughing)
- He's like I'm promoting. Oh
my god, look at the picture.
- [Tom] I know.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's my
favorite. I saw that picture.
Skin on skin is my favorite.
- Oh the best.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It really is.